now Goldman Sachs once called to a
reform of high-speed stock trading now
it wants to get back into the game
Bloomberg News is reporting that Goldman
has been hiring executives and investing
in software trading infrastructure and
it's dark pool back in 2014
Goldman's president Gary Cohen called
for reforms in the high-speed market so
is the bank trying to level the playing
field for its clients well here with me
to discuss this is the reporter who
broke that story for us Michael Moore
and also my co-host for the next hour
mark Crumpton so Michael why it seems
like an about-face by goldman sachs well
they would make the case that you can
have both you can have reforms and also
still be an active player in this
business but certainly they were trying
to get out ahead of some of the things
surrounding dark pools last year calling
for some market reforms and not much as
chain not that much has changed over the
last year and so you know they've
they're falling maybe a little behind
some of their competitors and want to
revamp some of their technology and get
back into this game you mentioned
Michael that they're falling behind that
competitors Goldman is in the position
now of having to play catch-up the
technological advances will they allow
Goldman to level the playing field
that's their hope you know there's two
ways of looking at it here the playing
field in terms of the overall market
getting their clients to the market as
fast as possible having the next best
execution and then leveling the playing
field with their competitors Goldman is
the top equity trading bank by revenue
at least last quarter yeah they fight it
out quarter to quarter with Morgan
Stanley those are the top two firms by
far but in this area Goldman has slipped
a little behind they want to get back to
number one in that so who are they
recruiting who are they hiring outside
to beef this up within Goldman they are
hiring they hired a managing director
from Morgan Stanley who's joining the
firm later this year there we heard
there are some more hires in the
pipeline and they're all they're out
there looking for
especially on the tech side Michael
Betty mentioned mr. cone and that op-ed
that England in The Wall Street Journal
last spring he said that the market
structure needed improvement because
risks were in his words amplified by the
dramatic increase in the speed of
execution and trading communications is
this now a question of improvements made
to Goldman's satisfaction or is it a
question of clients telling Goldman
demanding Goldman that they get back in
the game I think it's a little bit of
both I mean the Goldman has a lot of
quant funds you know the quantitative
hedge funds their clients have the prime
brokerage their clients of other parts
of the Bank and Goldman is saying we
need to have the top of class technology
to be able to service these funds in
this business as well so I think there
is some demand from clients you know
like like it or not this is how the
market structured and we need to be able
to execute in that